en 2015 le oxford dictionary qu'un truc
assez bas dassin quand même a comme
chaque année et lulu mot le plus
important de l'an écoulé et ce fut ce
mot là non pas le mot emoji mais bien
emoji directement et pas n'importe
lequel celui qui pleure de rire pourquoi
parce que d'après une enquête super
sérieuse des chercheurs on a observé que
c'était les mots jean le plus utilisé au
royaume-uni 1 et mogi à la place d'un
mot c'est peut-être pas si fou que ça en
fait les màj sonné au japon en 1999
grâce à un opérateur téléphonique qui
souhaitait rendre plus cool les grandes
stations à l'exception des jeunes et
enfin l on peut traduire emoji paris
images et mogi l'être car gilbert 2010
et les émaux j'y arrive chez nous via
gmail
apple android et enfin sur les réseaux
sociaux et aujourd'hui tout le monde les
utilise je suis certain que chacun
d'entre vous a déjà envoyé un coeur un
singe ou même une aubergine à ses amis
par l'auberge inception quand même en
une enquête estimé à 6 milliards le
nombre des mauges y envoyer chaque jour
sur les smartphones du monde entier est
sur liste à g en 2015 40 % des messages
contenaient au moins un et mogi donc les
énergies sont vraiment dans toutes nos
conversations virtuelles mais est ce que
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise chose
ça se fait au détriment des mots au
contraire ça permet de les compléter le
premier réflexe c'est de se dire que les
et bougies sont un petit peu trop
réducteur et efface des idées que seuls
les mots peuvent transmettre une liste
pictogrammes déjà enregistrés dans un
téléphone c'est forcément moins
exhaustifs que des milliers de mots qui
existe dans une langue du coup des gens
protester contre le manque de
représentation culturelle dans les
énergies genre miley cyrus par exemple
sur l'absence des mots j qui représente
les personnes noires et elle a fait
presque six krt oui oui a fait plein de
trucs bien aussi enfin je crois
et ça a eu un impact puisque tous ces
messages là ont été entendues
il ya eu donc l'incorporation de
personnages noirs latinos métissé
homosexuels il ya un problème c'est que
les màj sont vachement liés à notre vécu
et ça peut créer des soucis
d'incompréhension aussi on n'a pas tous
forcément les mêmes référentiels pour
traduire un même signal visuel par
exemple pour certains cette màj peut
symboliser le stress pour d'autres la
crispation ou encore la satisfaction est
celui-là peut vouloir dire tout va bien
comme
tu as vu juste en volume dans les pôles
t'oubliera pas tenir merci au delà nos
origines respectives la signification
qu'on va lui apporter ça va dépendre
notre éducation notre complicité avec la
personne est aussi une autre culture et
en même temps bah c'est ça qui fait leur
charme roses et bougies
bon parfois c'est carrément à cause des
constructeurs un même et mogi peut être
compris différemment suivant votre
appareil par exemple les moujiks on
vient de voir n'a pas le même degré de
positivité chez apple que chez les
autres un problème que peut poser une
utilisation exclusive des émaux j en
guise de langage c'est le manque de
nuance ou de profondeur pour exprimer
une même idée il existe une multitude de
mots si j'ai envie de dire que j'ai faim
je peux dire j'ai la dalle la fringale
le ventre qui gargouille un creux à
l'estomac 3 envie de bouffer ou un
besoin fou de me substanter 1 les mots
nous offre une diversité de langage
importante si je veux dire que j'ai fait
en et mogi je suis beaucoup plus limité
dans le choix je t'embrouille south à ce
sujet fin de berline mais là encore
c'est un peu chelou et ça peut paraître
encore plus handicapant dans l'autre
sens c'est un pote nous envoie le
message suivant j'ai vu un chien trop
mignon ont d'abord c'est les récessions
en bavent tout fragile mais surtout on
aura un minimum d'informations sur la
situation
quelle race de chien quelle taille
impossible transmettre toutes ces idées
uniquement par un dessin unique pour
tout bon il n'existe qu'un et mogi de
chiens d'ailleurs ça fait penser à la
capacité d'abstraction et aux idées
générales dont parle john locke je vous
avais déjà parlé dans un précédent de
coups de fil je vous remets le lien
vitré dans la description si vous cette
raison que les màj sont loin de
remplacer nos moyens d'écriture mais
quand même ça reste une opportunité
incroyable de communiquer tous ensemble
sans barrière de langue et à des
personnalités au rayonnement
international qui ont bien compris comme
kim kardashian qui donne le prénom de sa
fille avec l'idée de famille où hillary
clinton qui demande aux tweets hausse de
s'exprimer sur le prêt étudiant avec des
émaux lee mais là où je trouve ça fort
en termes d'impact c'est quand je pense
aux 16 % d'adultes dans le monde qui
souffrent d'analphabétisme un ces gens
qui n'ont pas la possibilité d'apprendre
à lire ou écrire pour quand même
communiqué par écrit car ça n'apportait
de beaucoup plus de monde de montrer et
comprendre un dessin d'ailleurs ça fait
penser à l'invention de la marque aikens
pic elle a imaginé ce t-shirt pour se
faire comprendre facilement dans le
monde entier on se sent pas à proprement
parler des émaux gym et ces mêmes
principes
ce sont des petits pictos qui illustrent
chacun une idée
après si un avion de la nourriture une
bière le wifi et vous suffit de pointer
du doigt le picto pour transmettre
d'informations
en fait on peut donc carrément se
demander si les images et les émaux j ne
serait pas un nouvel espéranto pour
rappel l'espéranto c'est une langue
internationale
imaginez en 1887 un par un jeune
polonais de 28 ans louis clés hier à
menchov dans le but de faciliter
l'entente et la compréhension des
peuples du monde entier
il ya des milliers de personnes et
d'associations qui tente de faire
perdurer et émerger ce langage et
finalement même si ça n'a absolument
rien à voir
ça c'est pas du tout dans le même
procédé les émaux j'y réponde aussi à
cet objectif tout en étant bien plus
simple à mettre en place
d'ailleurs l'aspect langue de lesmo j ai
aussi appuyé par le fait que c'est aussi
un mode de communication collaboratif il
évolue en même temps que la société et
les populations on a un vrai pouvoir sur
sa construction par exemple apple avait
sorti un et mauges et revolver il ya
quelques temps
et bien tout internet s'est mobilisée
pour transformer cette image et dayraut
final la communauté a gagné et c'est
devenu un pistolet à eau
on peut aussi parler du combat de raouf
al au média une adolescente de 15 ans
originaire d'arabie saoudite qui milite
pour intégrer le hidjab dans la
bibliothèque de dessin disponibles il
existe d'ailleurs une plateforme qui
permet à tout le monde de proposer et
voter pour des émaux ginon officiel afin
qu'il le devient un moyen des
communications collaboratives book et
les gens donnent une grande importance à
ce que ce nouveau langage reflète
parfaitement le monde tel qu'il est et
tel que ses habitants soit qu'ils
deviennent après ce que je trouve
vraiment intéressant c'est de la même
manière que les mots ont inspiré les
écrivains ou les poètes les émaux jcr et
aussi leur propre domaine artistique
les bougies art il consiste à revisiter
des oeuvres anciennes en les modernisant
en y injectant des dessins ou en
modifiant des mots par des émaux j c'est
ce qu'a fait par exemple katy perry avec
la version est modifiée de son clip
croire et on en est au tout début il ya
aussi le moma musée d'art moderne de new
york qui vient d'acquérir les premiers
emoji pour sa collection permanente
les lots j c'est pas une nouvelle langue
ces nouvelles manières d'écrire la
langue
une manière qui est collaborative
évolutive accessible inspirante fun et
s'attaque au barrière du langage et
offre la possibilité à chacun d'exprimer
ses idées avec émotion et créativité
alors certes on va pas pouvoir dès
demain échanger exclusivement qu'avec
des dessins mais les mots j pourrait
devenir un vrai mode de communication
internationale
grâce à son nombre de supporters
grandissant et sa capacité à être
utilisés réutiliser augmenter à l'infini
c'est pour ça que je tenais à vous en
parler on les utilise tous les jours on
a l'impression qu'ils bouffent la langue
on se rend pas forcément compte de ce
qu'ils apportent à nouveau prendre
conscience des dégâts à l'améliorer et
de donner à ce moyen de communication
l'image que l'on souhaite au sens propre
comme au sens figuré
le tout sans perdre le vocabulaire que
l'on a en ce cas ci les sms ne sont pas
à l'origine d'un déclin en orthographe
selon le cnrs
j'ai bon espoir que les ennemis ne vont
pas affecter notre vocabulaire
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
vous envoie du love et de la pisse à la
semaine prochaine
un gros merci à ceux qui soutiennent le
projet sur tipi merci beaucoup
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur tous les
réseaux n'hésitez pas à vous abonner si
ce n'était pas déjà fait et voilà vous
pouvez d'amour beaucoup des mots jr